- [Instructor] What we have here
is a really interesting visual
that shows world population growth
from 1750 all the way to 2100.
And obviously this isn't 2100 yet.
So it's doing some projecting
for roughly the next 80 years.
It also shows the
absolute world population
over that time period.
So just to make sure we're
understanding this graphic,
our horizontal axis here, we
can see the years going by.
You can view that as our time
axis, starting with the 1750
right over here, going
all the way to 2100.
Now we are here in, when
I'm making this video
is 2021 but this graphic was made in 2015.
So everything beyond 2015 is
considered to be a projection.
Now on this left-hand vertical axis,
this is really the rate of
world population growth,
the growth rate that it has here.
And I could write that down
just to make it more clear.
This is the growth rate axis
and we have a right vertical axis here
because we're really showing
two different things.
We're showing the annual growth rate
of world population in red.
And then we're showing the
absolute world population
in this blue curve right over here.
And so we could view this
axis as world population.
Now there's a bunch of really
interesting things here.
One, you might just wonder, well
what was the world population around 1750?
And if you look at this and
these are obviously estimates
because you did not have a
global census back in 1750,
it was around seven or 800 million people.
Now what's interesting is
that's not a lot larger
than the number of people
that we had at say the time
of Jesus, which is also the time
of the Roman empire and Han
China, where it's estimated
that at around that time
period around 2000 years ago
the world population was
around 300 million people.
But then we see something
interesting happening
over the next several centuries from 1750
it seems to start growing
pretty dramatically.
And we could see why that is.
We can see the growth rate
of population for a while.
If we look at this red
curve, the growth rate
of world population was
around 0.6%, but it looks
like in the early 20th
century, right around here,
the rate of growth of
world population starts
to really increase where
at least based on this
it looks like around the 1970s,
world population the growth
rate peaked out at 2.1%.
Now the question might be,
why was this happening?
Why did the rate of
growth increased so much?
Well, the main argument
is as we became a more
industrial society, healthcare
would have improved.
So child mortality would have gone down.
People would have died of fewer diseases.
At the same time
we would have gotten more
efficient with agriculture.
We would have had farming
methods, so more people
so food would get cheaper.
It would be more abundant.
More people would have access to nutrition
and all of those would
drive the growth rate up.
Now, an interesting question
that folks have been thinking
about for many hundreds
of years, is there a limit
to how much human population
the earth can sustain?
And so they've introduced this idea
known as carrying capacity.
Why do we use the letter K for
capacity when capacity starts
with a C, because a version
of that word in German starts
with a K and there's
always been this notion
that for a given species
there's gotta be some maximum capacity
that an ecosystem can sustain.
And there's folks like Thomas Malthus,
who's theorized that
there must be some limit
to how many people there
could be on the planet.
Just based on how much land there is,
how much nutrition or how
much resources there are.
But the carrying capacity
for humanity is really an open question
because our technology is
constantly on the move.
We constantly are getting better
at using our resources more efficiently
going into new ecosystems.
Now it's a huge debate.
How sustainable is that?
And as we become more efficient
are we also trashing certain
parts of our ecosystem
but the carrying capacity of humans,
we really don't know how many people
the planet earth could sustain.
But we could see that the
rate of population growth
starts to decline after 1970.
And the main argument for this,
and we've seen this and
recover this in other videos
when we study countries
that are still developing
and countries that would
be considered industrial
or even post-industrial,
is that as countries
develop and become wealthier
you might have more women
entering into the workforce.
You might have more family planning.
Women have more control
over their destiny,
get education longer, and
people just have fewer children.
And so as people have fewer children
you could see that the world that,
especially we see this in industrial
and post-industrial countries,
the growth rate starts to come down.
And so the aggregate growth
rate is coming down, arguably
because more and more countries
are becoming wealthier,
have better healthcare,
better rights for women.
And we even see today that
when you look at countries
that are developed being their
growth rate is around 1.2%
while more economically developed nations
aren't around 0.2%.
So there's definitely that
correlation between the two.
And of course, this growth
rate that you see in red
is going to affect the
absolute population.
And so it's no coincidence
that at the same time
that the growth rate
started to go up like that.
We see that the population
in absolute terms starts to accelerate.
And just over, let's say
the last hundred years
we've gone from 1.6, 5 billion.
I guess if we go back
a hundred years to 1920
it looks like we're
approaching 2 billion folks.
And now we're sitting
at roughly seven and a half billion folks.
So the world population roughly doubled
over the, last let's 2000
years prior to this chart.
But then over this chart
over just the last 270 years
our world population has grown pretty much
by a factor of 10.
Now we don't know how
sustainable that would be
if our growth rate were to continue,
but it does look like that
growth rate is moderating
and at least the projections in this chart
have a starting to approach
11 billion, maybe over time
12 billion and maybe stabilize
someplace around there.
But it's an interesting
thing to think about.